what's up gamespot fallen ghost DLC is
out for Ghost Recon wildlands
and I'm going to talk about it for a
minute then show you the intro cutscene
and cut to a sick infrared section where
I'm battling the new cloaked covert ops
enemies fallen ghosts has some new
weapons most notable is the demos and
Phobos crossbows they come with standard
and explosive bolts the explosive bolts
are unlocked in the skills menu the same
way as the underbarrel grenade launcher
my overall impression of the crossbow is
that it's really no better than any
other suppressed weapon in the game and
it eats up valuable space that could be
used for a sniper rifle but if you need
an extra grenades or for helicopters and
vehicles or you're just craving a new
weapon to play with it is pretty fun I
want to know what you guys think about
Ghost Recon wildlands at this stage are
you enjoying the casual tactical nature
of it would you like it to become more
tactical or are you waiting for that PvP
DLC to come out don't forget to throw us
the old like or subscribe so that we can
bring you more Roger goes - Holton zero
nine strands and no tracks detected at
this time nobody knows were here the AO
is planned over the term transit good
hunting ghosts actual out
go steam listen up two minutes to the LZ
get your gear together
so watch that launch
[Music]
where the hell did that come from it's
right on us
did anyone else make it down just us
some welcome
SATCOM feed is being jammed and they
knocked down the helo with a heat seeker
pretty high-tech stuff for some jungle
backwater so what's up plain as long as
one of us is alive the mission is still
a go
just spotted one with submachine guns
marking an enemy
you've got to be broke inside to do that
to a person
Oh
one
okay we're still all right I got a
target carrying submachine guns
I move into position let me get into
position hold up let me get a good
sideline I've got the target say the
word
munna dead bird on control watch out
this bad guy still good they found their
peak
Socrates this is nomad we've cleared
this place out loss Sexton Garros won't
be using the river anymore I've never
seen anything so grim would you've gotta
know you've done a righteous thing here
today doesn't feel that way not until
we've shut down these bastards for good